identify which of the following numbers
are integers and then plot them on the
number line so just as a reminder
integers are all of the whole numbers
they're negative counterparts and the
number zero so you can kind of view it
as well that's what you could view it as
so let's think about which of these are
whole numbers or negative whole numbers
I guess you could view them or zero well
five is clearly a whole number so that
is an integer negative two it's the
negative of a whole number so this right
here is also an integer
let's see point three clearly not a
whole number one third clearly not a
whole number negative one point two
clearly not a whole number or negative
counterpart of one 0 is an integer zero
is an integer
two is an integer clearly a whole number
9/7 not is one and 2/7 not a whole
number four point one is not a whole
number negative three it is the negative
of a whole number so this is also this
right there is also an integer so let's
plot it and they give us a nice number
line to ply it on so we have five five
sits right over here
I'll color-coded so that's five and we
had the negative two negative two sits
two to the left of zero so negative two
is going to sit right over there and we
have a 0 we have 0 over a year zeros
right over there and then we have to
we'd find a new color we have 2 this is
2 now I wanted to do a different color
we have 2 2 is 2 to the right 1 2 of 0
so that is 2 right over there and then
finally we have negative 3 and negative
3 will be 3 to the left of 0 1 2 3
negative 3 is right over there and we're
done